we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
we're back baby yeah
it's a new week with the same us boys
but this time we have our first guest
you got that right oh hell yeah
find a little estrogen in the house
right right right oh god
oh god all right that was
i guess we're gonna keep that all right
well rachel feinstein our good friend uh
is in the building you could just
introduce me as one of the guys
well you're here so we have to make you
like girly cocktails so we're making a
special
girly cocktail beer jew have you met
beer jew oh my gosh yeah he's our
in-house form of my grandpa zadie shout
out to zadie zadie in the house
lady [ __ ] killing it right now
you order drinks that are like
you know girly dumb [ __ ] drinks
i order what i ordered bartender
immediately decides that i'm a pointless
hole
i just ordered this such dumb drinks
like the exact order the drinks that the
girls that heckle me order like
pineapple a lot of pineapple vodka yeah
but i've graduated because the sugar was
making me too wildly ill so um
and now i just like
i like like a tequila soda or a vodka
treat but you could like i want to have
a good tequila but truly you could give
me well and i wouldn't know the
difference yeah you know what's funny is
our producer matt who is always on it
looks rachel up before the show and her
favorite drink is the negroni and i said
that's not true that's a lot he's
looking up a different rachel feinstein
oh my god that's the sculptor that i
always get confused with sculptor and
yes there's a famous can i tell this
story right here pull her up
here who's hotter there's a famous
sculptor she's hotter she's really hot
oh come on and and she's a famous
sculptor and she gets you got the first
google search hey
[Applause]
i just want to thank my team eg
[Laughter]
no she's um she's a sculptor and she was
like on the cover of like she was like
they did an article rather about her in
vogue
and she's like best friends with like uh
mick jagger
and she just has this life i've wanted
like her husband painted her for years
and then he met the woman he'd been
painting like it's just like
like a man he's never adored me like
that like my brother's always dating
women like like his wife it's just like
everything she does is adorable i've
never had a man feel like that about me
like as soon as they meet me they get
angry at what a pig i am i've never had
but you couldn't be with that guy if he
was like rachel my darling you'd be like
oh
i want that like when i see a man when i
see like get a like a like a like a
celebrity couple at a knicks game and he
just has one the guy has one hand on her
lower back i project so much onto their
relationship i'm like he protects her in
a way
that was the saminaj on my back
so rachel um feinstein
is um fried as hell and uh
she um look at this i get i keep getting
all i know they have like a famous
rachel has a beautiful baby oh that's
right the most beautiful children i've
ever seen me you weren't yeah i'm not
just saying that because i'm a pedophile
i really mean it
but can i just say that um frankie is a
very beautiful kid and she's very fond
of you usually she's um suspicious of
men and actively terrified of nederman
but she yeah
but i just want to say that rachel
feinstein the sculptor so i would get
calls from my my manager saying offering
me things this happened to me he was
like they want to do a story about you
and your fashion choices and they're
gonna like highlight you and vogue so i
walked around with like
fashion profile confidence i'm like i do
take some risks
i was telling everybody i'm like yeah i
could say that like i shop at like
forever 21 i'm like true true [ __ ] with
fashion but i believed for like weeks
that vogue wanted to do a profile on me
and then i got quietly uninvited to the
profile they're like oh yeah they uh
actually don't they want this other
woman and then they called me and they
were like do you wanna um oprah wants to
invite you to private
wow
invited the guy
that i'm now married like by at the he
was like we were just starting to date
at the time and i was like so oprah is
intrigued by me
i'm gonna bring my brooklyn fireman
husband and i had to tell him that she
was not like do you know you walk
differently if you think oprah is the
dream of course like that's a whole new
level of confidence and then again i
just got softly changed your next title
of your album to one of oprah's favorite
things
and then they were like um i called my
manager i was like listen they said it's
the other rachel feinstein's the
sculptor were really sorry and i was
like listen i already invited the guy
i'm dating i cancelled a [ __ ] gig
because i thought i was going to meet
oprah can you just call them
i mean it was like something perfectly
worthless
but uh but i was like can you just see
if you could like get us in it's too
actively humiliating to tell this guy
i'm newly dating that oprah doesn't want
to meet me after all it's horrifying
so i told them and they were like if
your boy your boyfriend's like i
actually i'm gonna be honest i thought
you were the sculptor rachel feinstein
as well
very confusing
so they called back and they're like i
was like just get us in if you can and
he's like yeah they're pretty firm that
you're not to attend
i think they had a picture of me like at
the front door like the security guard
on the photograph like do not let it i
like the guys
[Laughter]
oh let's try this drink what do we got
here beer jew this is uh basically like
a watermelon basil tequila concoction
it smells incredible like the the smell
coming off this
smells good like a pad thai
boy dude this is so good that is
delicious really good refreshing
watermelon
basil
we know dan we know
in our buddy
um i should have listened the first time
that's not good radio um to ask you
again what it is but now i want this to
be my drink because it's really
satisfying he'll make anything really
delicious though he's good we'll call it
the rachel right or i don't know which
rachel finds him maybe we'll get right
now the rachel was a sandwich we'll call
it
jennifer anderson's friend's haircut oh
that's right yeah yeah she's from new
york jennifer anderson yeah i think so
isn't the rider rumor about jennifer
anderson the one about getting the green
m ms picked out no that's not her
is it that's old i think so yeah that
came before her that guy's like led
zeppelin or something yeah
ozzy that winston churchill there you go
he loved eminem's that's what
[Music]
van halen van halen that was it
and it was all just to see if they would
do it
they're paying attention yeah
interesting oh i see
have you you have a writer yes and like
it's literally nothing on it and there's
and it's i mean there's like two of the
saddest like it shows you my self-esteem
when you read what's on the same same
telling i'm just like my writers just
says like i'm sorry i'm here and i'll
see myself out
uh there's like just like any protein
bar sorry yeah
just like a protein bar water and
sugar-free red bull that'll get me
through the late show none of it's ever
there at like why don't you do you're a
red bull person
i mean i'm not i don't want to be a red
i don't want to identify that way but i
just need some caffeine to get me
through the late show but when i order
it i'm actively humiliated you know bob
saget i just did bob saget's podcast and
he said he was offered
uh a buy-in when red bull was getting
off the ground for like 20 grand he
would have had a huge steak in red bull
and he took a sip and was like this
stuff tastes like [ __ ] um yeah i mean it
does taste like ass yeah
oh god i hate myself already the only
thing worse than red bull is when you
drink with red bull those people are
like give me a red bull and vodka you're
like ooh if you have one i don't judge
you but once you have more than one oh
yeah i just don't like red but i
remember i was at a bar once uh
at pj clark's in the bartender someone
ordered a red bull and he goes we only
do coffee here and he said it was such
disdain and i kind of respected it hell
yeah
it was a badass move yeah i respect i
also have skinny pop on it which nikki
said was good i called nikki and asked
her what i should put in her glazes
because i knew that she respected
herself a little more than i respect
women love popcorn it's good for you
well it's locale it's locales yeah i
assume it'd be one of oprah's favorite
things yes
but but i always feel like even when i
ask for like almost nothing none of it's
there they'll be like they know what i'm
worth and they're correct like i'll get
there and they'll be like like
literally just like a do-rag or like a
nickel or something
like an afro pick uh what's that what's
your ride all i have is protein bars
bananas and uh
beef jerky because to me beef jerky is
the height of luxury i'm like man a bag
is 6.99 yeah so i get them to buy it
they are good oh it's great i love a
jerk the problem with the jerky is
though it's so you want to keep it
special now it's i'm kind of like used
to it because i get it every week
so took the the fun out of it's like
having christmas every day
yeah
it's satisfying though i like it i love
it i do fresh fruit and uh that's good
fresh fruit's good and then uh
iced coffee always oh yes i asked for
cold brew that's true cold brew and you
get a little oat milk in there you get a
nice little coffee before the show you
wake up a little bit that's not bad
cobra gives me the anxiety though a lot
of clubs will just have liquor in there
too which is a weird move they're like
we got you liquor i'm like don't you
guys have a full bar like you didn't
have to
buy me liquor that's true i think it's
because it's a podcast yeah probably
this is making me realize like where i'm
at because these things don't happen to
me
and then they just give you sneakers
right and then you're like i got shoes
off eddie griffin though oh really you
heard that story right no new air force
one sneakers every weekend and he
doesn't take them either
he just does it it's a control thing
that's how he's spherical i love a power
booster for the waiter working that
weekend like all right i'll take these
yeah that's nice
yeah
have you been on the road a lot lately
uh yes i have been on the road a lot
lately where have you been
where was i last week in springfield
missouri not named drama
it's actually a pretty fun club there's
good yeah that guy's so nice chris he's
a good hang like he walks you all the
way up to your room like whatever you
need to bring he'll walk you he'll take
you up to there he tries to get in the
room he's like come on
kiss
no i mean he does he's so sweet he
fingers you
i think i just want to make sure
everything's good right yeah
yeah yeah no he's great he that's in
your writer i think he was a part of
kanye west's presidential campaign
what i think he was wow
he was like i'm not in the city right
now because i'm working with kanye and i
was like what i thought was a joke and
then he's like no i'm like trying to get
it off the ground it sounds like a joke
i forgot he ran
yeah he get do you ever have this when
somebody takes you around he took me
around like town and he was giving all
the facts of the town you know and they
were hysterical he was like on this
corner uh the first munch house disease
diagnosis was given i was like that is
the best small town fact i've ever heard
he's like first munch house and he's
like i know a friend that [ __ ] her
those are the saddest facts they're
known for cashew chicken there that's
right that's the thing that's bringing
it
invented cashew chicken and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is cashew chicken it's
some kind of chinese food yeah yeah what
do you mean what is it you should know
it well yeah christmas yeah there it is
oh you i was always a general sews guy
really yeah i guess you're right you
were because i've gone to china it's
just weird that it's born in missouri
cashew chicken
it is pretty good it's all right yeah
it's no kung pao
is great is kung pao what's your go-to
orders at chinese place um
pepper steak
really oh yeah i love the beef and
broccoli oh i do like i guess i like
sesame chicken or mixed vegetables mixed
vegetables if i start to think about
meat like in that type of situation
i go for the sesame chicken's is it
sesame chicken is general so is it
transitioned you know it's just yeah i
just went through a little thing
what is the difference is there a
difference the seeds ah
by the way you guys are we on camera
because i can sit differently if i know
no no we're on camera but you're looking
great everything no no i'm gonna look
fat if i sit like you can move that out
of them if you want
women are gonna hate you because rachel
is is so thin and and and you can't you
can't just say you're like i'm fat when
you you're so thin oh thank you saying
that but um people tell me online so
that's where i get a lot of money sorry
about that that's a good place to get
weight loss tips yeah that's true good
motivation yeah like i'll get people
arguing about me like this guy mr waffle
said always right
i was up at like three in the morning
reading all my comments you're never
supposed to do that there's no god
mr trot waffles that hates me and he'll
give me a brand new insecurity [ __ ]
waffles he's really active under my
videos and there's other guys that stick
up for me and he's like he's like total
man voice you know wooden [ __ ]
whatever right right but he must love
you if he's watching everything that's
that's the weird fine line yeah the thin
line between love and hate i don't know
i mean well they become if they comment
on everything they're i guess you're
right he seems so against me and then
there's this other guy in my feeder 69
that sticks up for me and he's like if
you if you put if you have a youtube
profile and you get the comment there
should have to be like
like a bio attached yeah if you get to
if you get to weigh in we we should get
to know something about you right it'd
also be fun to check the other rachel
feinstein and see if [ __ ] waffles
are we calling this the other rachel
feinstein this episode you got that
right
the sculptor the sculpt
you sculpt your act you're an artist
no such thing
but she but i have to say like
um i'm a little drunk already where are
we she's talking about what a life
aren't these good yes she was hammered
what you got here for the record
is there blow on my nose
that's a little blood there no wait wait
i had something to say about what we're
doing oh uh waffles oh yes swat waffles
so then he goes to and then he goes
you know muffeter was sticking up for me
and he was like come on man do you think
she actually has time to read this [ __ ]
she's out living her life of like one
point for 12 waffles because here i am
this is an avengers i would watch this
squat waffle versus buffeter and
superheroes the extended universe of the
internet commenters exactly
now we're getting somewhere marvel pick
it up man that's uh that's one thing
though men don't get i've never had uh a
woman defend me on like
you know youtube comments i feel like a
nice guy will chime in and be like hey
buddy don't say that to her i mean but
they're so they're so furious that's
called white knight i mean i look at
sam's videos i'm like great guy i love
the act like you know keep going sam go
get him it's like they're cheering on a
baseball team and mine are just like
dumb [ __ ] die like
youtube comments for women it's
definitely a different oh no oh yeah
they hate us in a wild way like just
they're aggressive there's danger in the
comments like you're like oh these
people would harm me if they yeah
we get like homo and stuff like that
what a douche
[ __ ] yeah
cuck
i'm kind of like you think [ __ ] hurts
me i call myself a [ __ ] i know you
can't do worse than this noggin
for insults do you let it affect you
mark oh yeah oh yeah and i don't read
every comment i read them all and the
messages and everything and the worst is
when they get one right you know it's
one thing if you call me a a
a gay guy or something i'm like all
right i can deal with that but if you're
like he says this a lot you're like oh i
do yeah they give you good notes
sometimes that hurt yeah and i was like
i do say i don't even know that oh my
god that that's what [ __ ] me up
yeah when they're right when it's when
it is like semi-constructive yes when
you're like yeah i could stand uh uh
have better word economy yeah yeah yeah
one guy wrote he says i don't know a lot
and i i watched it i was like i said i
don't know like ten times wow crushed me
damn i mean but that's not yeah i know
that that arrests me but then when i
hear it about you i'm like that's kind
of helpful like it's not helpful but
when you just feel vulnerable and so
seen
yes that's it because you're just so
exposed because you get up on stage and
like especially like like a stylist will
put me in an outfit and then i'll like
look at it later i'm like i look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then all the
comments and everything everything you
put on that you put on later never looks
as good there's you get close goggles
when like when i'm at the store and i
put something on i'm like this works and
then i get home and i'm like i look like
[ __ ]
yeah
like i take these big swings and i feel
like a fool a lot of times like you
never wear it again yes like a stylist
told me to wear these like shiny tiger
boots and i'm like oh i look like a
freshly divorced like real estate agent
searching for the next one
flipping house i do i look like like a
just like a
the kind of woman that would like pick
up somebody at an airport bar like and a
lot of the things that i get put in and
then when i get out i got to the club in
springfield and somebody on that lineup
was like
uh he was like oh boots
yeah you're having a crazy night and
like right then i was like oh just kill
yourself rachel like
just him just noticing my sassy choice i
was so immediately disgusted with myself
you know like he's like oh boots i'm
like god damn it oh yeah that enough
will just make me want to throw them in
the trash i don't mean to notice
that's the sign of a good dresser if you
can't at least in my opinion if i can't
remember what a man's wearing for men if
i can't remember what a guy's wearing
then he's a good dresser because you
know because
big swings speaking of swings like i
don't want to see a man you know i want
to be i want to be [ __ ] wade boggs i
just want to get on base i don't want i
don't want i don't want to be hitting
home runs you see these people that are
like this guy's a good dresser i'm like
he's wearing a fedora like that's a
[ __ ] ballsy move yeah yeah yeah
that's tough you gotta be like dressers
are generally don't want to be inside of
you that's what i feel like as a woman
like if he's a really fine
like he doesn't want to be
inside a woman what's that it's like
being a great dancer if you're like
doing the tango you're just you're gonna
be like i don't want to [ __ ] i just did
the tango you know
i thought women like dancing guys i
don't know i don't know either it's
tough i feel like
america latin american and black guys
they they can cut a rug and it's fine
but if there's a white guy like
that dance was amazing it was good
that could be like that's a gift is that
a good that is a gift yes please give us
a shot
i've seen men do that yeah and i usually
have a vest on you ever seen you ever
like a wedding and you just see a guy a
comic you know break out and good and
you're like you can dance ryan hamilton
brian hamilton he can kill him
he can't he can cut a little fine rug
and a good dresser by the way he is
because you know what he certain people
yeah he wears like kind of well-fitting
jackets you get old and you realize all
you need is for the clothes to really
fit yeah yeah
but that's the thing is the chain the
fit changes in the 90s it was
loosey-goosey and now it's tidy whitey
yeah what
i think he's got
shirts got tired you see blazers 90s
like you watch like old episodes like
seinfeld you're like that's a baggy
[ __ ] blaze exactly where you see like
larry sanders yeah like you're wearing a
double-breasted blazer like the suit
pants are this wide it's like a zoot
suit but that's coming back in for women
which is that's how i covered my
pregnancy i just wore a lot of
polypeptide blazers
i just dressed like b arthur the entire
time i was pregnant right i didn't know
you weren't supposed to hide it like i
was like whispered all my friends like
don't tell anyone i'm
i hit it like a catholic teenager who
gave it someone gave it away at the
seller didn't they well [ __ ] keith he
kept going like why is rachel's body
disappointing all of a sudden
he's like everybody let's do a fun quiz
what's wrong with rachel's body do you
think he when you wore a blazer once to
the seller he did what do you call you
like a district attorney or something
like rachel dresses like a district
attorney that one hurts so bad
because it was so accurate it was such a
perfect
yeah i do dress like a district attorney
or like at least a legal assistant you
know a lot of times i feel like i dress
like a woman leaving an abusive
relationship
like there's a wildness to my choices
keith is an incredible ball buster he's
the best i remember he's so funny i
auditioned to the seller i remember i
didn't even know him and he was just
like look at him look how scared he is i
was like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this guy well he cuts to the truth yeah
that's what he's good at he just zones
in on that it's never a mean truth it's
always like a truth that's really funny
right right it's really funny but often
but he's so smart about it but often
well i've had people ball bust where
they're like that joke sucks or whatever
and i'm just like oh it's not good no
like i'm ball busting like that's not
that's like the actual thing people
would right that's an insult that's like
yeah you know mark does that but he's
worked on it
it used to be that whenever i saw mark i
was like just get prepared to have your
feelings violently hurt
i didn't know i was doing it when you
went to therapy for like a few months
you got a little gentler yeah yeah
i was out of love you know it was like
hey
i thought i was doing what keith was
doing
[Laughter]
yeah but keith will say something that
like like you ever do is where you leave
like nobody sees that like i had a huge
zit and i've had like terrible acne my
whole life and i'm like nobody's
thinking about it you're right yeah
you're the one who sees it i get to the
seller and he's like why is rachel's it
blinking at me
rachel's zick keeps winking at me god
damn it and i was like [ __ ] like it just
i don't want to be outside anymore like
that's it i wanted to just be buried
under the ground he's good ugh it was
quite the same way they just know how to
[ __ ] on you i remember i showed up with
a mustache once and quinn was like you
know what really bugs me as you think
this looks good he just really was
furious yeah they were all angry that i
had a mustache they hate it that bugs me
i remember one time derosa showed up
with a brand new leather jacket
big mistake
and uh keith goes oh it looks like he
bought your attitude jacket oh and
derosa was like
he just took it off i mean he got him
you can't really take fashion risks at
the comedy no
if you if you roll in and you're and
you're i mean that's probably why
we dress so conservatively because if
you take a risk and you ch even if you
chan any big change anything noticeable
yeah if you go in if i rolled in in a
blazer they're just like what are you
doing yeah yeah who do you think you are
doing oh this is oh this is your blazer
this is your corporate act you're gonna
do it yes yes exactly but do you guys
have the thing where you're at the gap
or h m and you're putting things on i
just hear people going what do you
create you can't pull that off you suck
you're not you can't wear that so i just
i don't buy it
do you have that in the dressing room or
is that just yes i have it in my mind
all day all day all day it's just [ __ ]
who do you think you are yeah you're a
fool and everyone knows your number
everyone knows you're full of [ __ ]
because and also it and it happens to us
so like whatever self-esteem we might
have developed has been beaten out i
feel like from just what we've done to
our psyches by going into stand-up like
just the
just the nature of the career alone i
feel like what would i have been like
had i not done this to my mind and like
starting my right now we'd be much
happier probably if we didn't stand up
but i mean like i love sculptor but we
would be happier but we wouldn't have as
much fun yeah i mean like i feel like
that's true we would be more at peace
but we would but we just have the most
fun everyone's depressed i think yeah
everyone's got [ __ ] you know like like
even people that are like things are
going great like you don't see them when
that goes down when they come down from
that there's a come down from that too
good people did realize that during
covid that and you're right that
everybody is sizzling with mental
illness oh my god oh yeah you just
scroll on twitter and you're like oh
good nobody is healthy good right
yeah
but at least at least hurt yourself i
like when people hurt themselves like i
love a cutter that's a great you know
wait a second why do you lose this what
the [ __ ] are you talking about because
at least with a cutter you're like i'm
going through [ __ ] cut me but other
people try to cut you you love a
i know but that's the thing i surprised
about mark is he can't hear his words
i'm being funny i'm joking
you guys don't realize i'm joking why
are we doing well okay okay
i don't think people know i'm joking
okay well you're joking and we're trying
to [ __ ] yes and you by all right all
right by being you know but yeah i don't
know anybody because you are i did when
you say outrageous i have to go voice
and reason that's that's what comedy is
i have to explain what i'm doing all
right well i just didn't know if you
actually knew no i know you're [ __ ]
kidding people to harm themselves you're
a comedian yeah i [ __ ] all right all
right just check i've known you for how
long this is a comment section
sorry what were we going to say rach i
cut you off there
the comment section is going to be like
mark and sam wore that
i know right i'm waiting for it
i mean
i think i do think that um
i have nothing to say actually oh come
on
give her another one she'll spill the
beans in two seconds i was gonna try to
whip something that's so funny
i'm at the doctor this morning getting
injections in my neck crazy because uh
because i you know my neck is [ __ ] and
the doctor's like all right no alcohol
and i was like oh i have a drinking
podcast and he was like what yeah we
have a podcast where we drink i have to
have at least one and he was like all
right you can have one
do you get a note with the doctor
because i feel like this could get you
out of for you to tell me well you can
get out of a world mark i'm like it says
i can't drink today and you're like all
right i guess right um
what do you mean a note well you know
how people say having doctors know but
i've never actually seen a doctor what i
use it for well i want to do my job i
know i was making a joke if you don't if
you want to get out of eating a girl out
like my neck my neck uh it feels like a
curb episode
ah you look at the neck thing i can't be
in that position
you can blow me though
you guys i i just thought about how
greasy i must look when i'm putting on
powder take in the sadness of that no
grease you look fine you look great
you're talking about it no grease you're
smart you're funny you're just a little
insecure people like you there's no
mirror here
al franken yeah he's at the cellar now
somebody called me greasy in a video and
i was like i am greasy i'm a greasy ass
[ __ ] greasy greasy even mean i know
it's a temporary steak greasy is good i
had one where i was sweating and
somebody goes he's so shiny and i was
like ah wasn't the time you had food
poisoning though yeah that was bad mark
taped this comedy central half hour
it was he had food poisoning so he was
sweating his ass off pull up a photo i
look like a different person whoever did
the makeup for those half hours made us
all orange i know
i look like you have a picture of me
samuel half hour if you can i look
orange dude we look like the real
housewives it's way overdue it's a half
hour special uh man for both of us you
know we all look orange someone just
posted one
yeah there it is the first one the blue
first one look how orange i am oh yeah
aren't you glad you're not sam
let's see more pulled mine a half hour
special i i had h pylori it wasn't even
food poisoning it was a virus oh look at
that look how fat and bloated i was you
look different i took an antibiotic i
went back down in one day damn look at
me i look like a [ __ ] you don't you
would never john panetta you look fat or
bloated you look handsome actually oh
get out look at that one look at me i'm
like a [ __ ] uh
jack-o'-lantern jesus you look surprised
there you look you look like you're
taking a [ __ ] and someone opened the
stall i was actually [ __ ] down my
pants like i had the bubbles in the back
really diarrhea all day long this is
this virus it's called h pylori it was a
nightmare you get it from eating feces
yeah what is it you get it from uh
ingesting feces
damn i ate a ate a gal's back door in
wisconsin yeah which sounds like a
country song
yeah yeah i'll send you the video i love
that beer
really
i'm joking there's no video i believed
you
i need content her back door which which
city in wisconsin
madison
i was newly singled i went on a tear
yeah and i was like so did she yeah
and we were i learned about ass eating
that was new then you know it was hot
that was trending yeah
ludicrous thing to say hashtag i learned
about ass eating that was when it was
getting its start exactly
athletic has been around since the early
1990s i don't know i've never heard of
it in the 80s oh your great-grandfather
was one of the fighters
winston churchill
brown eminem mark norman
one of the finest butthole lookers of
all where's that ken burns the ass
eating uh the history slow zoom out
he always liked to lick a bud uh soft
jazz
mountain
[Laughter]
do you uh
we do peeves on this podcast we do our
complaints it's kind of like our it's
our convection
yeah yeah any any peeves this week what
grinds your gears um
uh first of all uh wait can i look at my
phone because i just wrote down one of
my peeps i have some complaints about my
husband for he's like
all right
babe if you're watching this
you better watch out cause i'm not
he wouldn't watch it that's the saddest
part he would never have even do you
want i don't want my significant other
to watch me on you know speaking of
peeves my husband will like um
like i don't care that he's not like
particularly enthralled with my stand up
but he'll lay in bed next to me and
laugh like wildly at something on
college humor
you want to see my special at any point
like that's fun that's how it's done
and every one of my boyfriends has been
like this like like there was a time
where i did like a commercial
and i was thinking like
and like i'm taping this commercial in
l.a and he'd never been to l.a before so
i'm thinking like what is he thinking
now i had the most narcissistic thought
i'm like as i'm shooting this is he
gazing over like intrigued by my life
and he's like he walked to me over to me
slowly you know when you kind of open
your body language up to be complimented
oh yeah
he was like the pool's only open for
another hour can i go back to the hotel
that just like sums up how deeply
underwhelmed he is like i
i'll be like my special was like airing
that day and he's just like you gotta
love this guy i mean that's how it's
done and he'll
i dated one guy that he loved that movie
with the rock and his niece and oh
not
again
it was like it was like hulk hogan did a
version of it mr nanny oh yeah remember
when hulk hogan was like a leading oh
yeah yeah that was that was a bad time
i watched all of you guys
he would be like he loved when um
when big people and little people hung
out together you'd be like come on he's
so big he kept re-pitching it to me like
i didn't understand the concept he's
like he's so big and she's so tiny i
mean you do the math like i got it yeah
i got it yeah i think but it's great
he's like a big dude he's like doing
stuff with this little tiny oh my god i
understand has he seen the movie twins
i gotta show him that they did a little
uh
junior
oh right right i forgot about that that
was uh
danny devito though dude i mean that guy
[ __ ] oh he's great
i watched zoe sunny
so like that's my comfort show on the
road do you ever watch joey sunny in
philadelphia i do like that show it's a
really funny show there's something
about it though like i don't know when
my partner when i date someone i don't
need her to like love my act i just need
you need that occasional like oh that
was funny
i did a comic so a lot of the times like
comics don't laugh at jokes like i'll
tell you she's like oh what's your what
any new stuff i told her when she's just
like oh yeah that's good and it's like
it's weird to just get that yeah but
that's that's how i am too that's how
comics react to like
when you think it's hilarious you just
think about it you think about how good
it is you're analyzing it what makes me
laugh out loud is like
craziness it's like silly [ __ ] like a
silly yeah silly stuff something
outrageous i will say as i as i like
insult the fact that he loves movies
about big men and tiny women that i love
like the dumbest tropes will make me
laugh more than anything in the world so
like i love it when um when somebody's
told to leave someplace and comes back
in again
[Laughter]
like when somebody's like told seriously
to leave a party they're like you're out
of hand get out of here then they come
back in a different outfit always funny
to me really somebody's sneaking back in
it's like you know like in like in like
trading places like all like those old
comedy movies where they're like told to
leave a fancy party and then come back
in a fun loving hat always funny to me i
also like it when couples insult each
other like they're married but they're
like you're dumb that's why oh you love
them stupid i like it because you've
made the decision to marry somebody and
it's very funny to me that you just turn
around you're like because you're in an
idiot yeah because your brain can't hold
a lot that's why yeah that's one of my
favorite scenes ever is
in back to school when rodney's wife is
leaving him
you know he's divorcing her she just
caught it with someone else and he just
hands you she goes i want a divorce and
go so i knew we had something in common
he takes the papers out of his jacket he
goes sign here she goes oh you're not
getting out of this out of it this easy
yeah and he just takes that he goes oh
you want to talk about class because you
guys got no class because you're right i
married you didn't i yeah
because you want to talk about class
here's you with the here's you with this
guy here's you with this guy he's you
he's this guy but what's with the [ __ ]
it's like
rodney just zinging her yeah and
she cheats on him so he's just licensed
to say [ __ ] it right right yes i love
that he's like we need a button on this
[ __ ]
she goes you're impossible he goes oh
yeah and you're easy
just heard those specific jokes because
my husband's my father-in-law every time
i go over to his house he's like you
know what you should know you should do
that rodney dangerfield his suggestion
is always that i steal rodney
dangerfield's act he's like that's what
you should do and then he plays it
really loud whenever like at an alarming
level like just 15 and he's like that's
what you go on
he's like that's comedy like he just
wants me to literally steal rodney
dangerfield's entire act yeah and just
go on stage and deliver it it's
fascinating and he goes and remember
take pauses you got to take pauses
sheath review giveaway baby
sheath underwear we might be drunk are
working together to give you the comfort
of the most comfortable and best looking
underwear in the market it really is
both am i wearing it right now too
oh no i'm not all right sam's but i
don't i don't like these dude i'm doing
i ran out of underwear because the
laundry day so i'm doing the over the
top i hate the over there not the over
the top good movie though
uh all you need to do is leave us a five
star rating and write a review on apple
podcast take a screenshot of the view
the review submit the screenshot fill
out the form we will be giving away a
number of under uh underwear every
episode during the month of november so
write your review and fill out the form
so we know what underwear size and where
to send the underwear visit
gothampodcaststudio.com
wmbd
fill out the form and let us give you
some free underwear yeah big thanks to
sheath underwear for sponsoring this
promo don't forget to use promo code
drunk for 20 off your purchase with
sheath underwear oh yeah we love them
wearing them right now what better
promo is that they're cupping my
genitals as we speak all right we might
be drunk is also brought to you by lucy
nicotine gum
everybody who tries to quit smoking it's
hard there's books about it there's
lectures there's ted talks there's
hypnotists all this stuff but quitting
smoke is the hardest thing you'd ever do
but not with lucy baby lucy was founded
by caltech scientists former smokers who
want to help other people quit they set
out to create a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative it took three years
of research but they made lucy a
nicotine gum that actually tastes good
comes in wintergreen cinnamon
pomegranate and if you don't like gum
they got lozenges baby citrus mint or
cherry ice
whew i like the citrus
goes down easy yeah yeah i used to chew
this just for a little jolt each has
four milligrams of nicotine when you're
craving a smoke you need a little
something to satisfy that habit get your
fix lucy's got you baby subscribe
monthly too and they'll send it right to
your house tell them how sloppy jalopy
they're supporting this show so go to go
god [ __ ] damn it we're not even
drinking yet there's support i think
we're better with the alcohol maybe it
loosens uh us up a little bit they're
supporting the show so go support them
get 20 off all products including gum or
lozenges at lucy.co with codedrunk
that's 20 off
lucy.co and use promo code drunk at
checkout and here's the part the lawyers
make us say
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical but what isn't these
days am i right good point no duh get 20
off at lucy.co with code drunk oh yeah
here we go we might be drunk it's also
brought to you by sheath underwear you
know it we know it i'm wearing it right
now sheath is the best in the business i
just gave myself a melvin pulling this
puppy up and uh they feel good they look
good my lady likes them she got her own
stuff
it's men and women they cup the genitals
they separate the dick and the balls
yeah it's it's it's needed to happen
these two needed some space yeah i'm
against segregation but with dick and
balls
let's get them separated shoes in
palestine baby uh love sheath they look
good they feel good not only supportive
keeps your balls off your legs two
pouches one for the dick one for the
balls and she's in just for men
you uh lady gays out there can get
sheath two sports bras bikini briefs
boys shorts oh i love those boys shorts
that's a little ironic
a man a straight guy likes boy shorts
all right the idea for sheath came from
its former or its founder u.s army
soldier robert patton during his second
tour in iraq support this awesome
veteran-owned company whose founder is a
big comedy fan all right robert go to
sheath underwear dot com and order with
promo code drunk to get twenty percent
off your first order and sheath
underwear's hundred percent money back
guarantee that sheath underwear dot com
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
and let them support
your balls yeah ooh good good read at
the end there they're [ __ ] it is good
underwear it really is and they sent us
a million pairs one minute block
time.com it's full of articles
explaining blockchain
ethereum and it takes less than one
minute to read we all know how
crypto is big everybody's in it you feel
left out everybody's doing it and i
don't understand it i'm an idiot but
this guy is gonna explain it to you
investing how complex nfts work bitcoin
you name it so they're not giving out
financial advice but
oneminuteblocktime.com is a great place
to start learning about it so good he
says that to me every time he sees me so
i was like apparently they say you're a
comedian like he still doesn't buy the
rumors yeah that's what i do for a
living but that's why we like rodney
because that's our ultimate fantasy is
to be in a horrible situation like that
and always have a zinger yeah you're
right that's all it is that's why people
like heckler videos yeah because yeah
they're living vicariously through you
like that's their boss that's the right
thing there's justice in that moment
it's something about rodney that's so
comforting right because that's also
what all like that's what i spend most
of my time doing is over like replaying
small social exchanges like some people
are afraid of death like i don't death
bring it on i care if people are mad at
me that's all the jerks
they're running out of you yeah
i worry so much more if i rub someone
the wrong way than if i die just like a
violent gangrenous death so much think
about it
so many flights i was on a flight the
other day that was like it felt like the
engine stopped going i was like oh we're
gonna die it was like one of those
moments you always look at the
at the flight attendant to see how she's
doing yes me too and she was okay and
that was the only thing i was like oh
god thank god yeah but then also part of
me is like well maybe she's just okay
with death
right right maybe she's like if this
goes down shit's been bad like i'm a
flight attendant during a pandemic
people are [ __ ] bring it on i can't
have no sympathy i was sitting next to a
lady the other night on a flight and she
was like oh god she had like a thick
southern accent she was like a cute kind
of southern hayseed lady you know like
it's my first time flying you know i was
like oh it'll be fine it'll be punched
like i'm so scared i'm so scared when
she said a prayer and all that it was it
was endearing but you're also like come
on
shut up the plane's going down you're
like shut up you hick
yeah you [ __ ] hillbilly
peter pretzel
oh man there's a part of me i'm on the
flight uh
you know and they do oh someone's got a
peanut allergy so we're not serving
peanuts today and
i wasn't even planning on eating peanuts
but there's a party that's like [ __ ] him
yeah [ __ ] him right right that's true i
i could have had peanuts i know i wasn't
planning on it you know so why announce
it to us just don't give us the [ __ ]
pizza i bring nuts on the on the plane
with me i could just still belt them out
oh good point here's the other thing
it's like i don't i only want the
peanuts now that i know i can't have
them right
you want what you can't have yeah it's
true before you're like peanuts [ __ ]
this peanuts they're still serving this
[ __ ] yeah i can't have him like i can't
have a [ __ ] salty snack
i still hate biscoff i know we fight
about bischoff is [ __ ] class thanks i
i associate it with being hungover on a
7am flight out of denver well that's
your fault for taking the 7am flight
well i want to get home
i kind of agree with you both of you
like there's a sadness to a biscoff
cookie there it is and it's packaging
but yet it's still a cookie
dip it in the coffee it's really good
it's a good coffee dunk i eat it but i
agree there's a low grade depression to
about yes and it's this packaging that's
obviously cheap and the cookie's cheap
but they try to make it seem
snazzy and biscoff you know it almost
seems kind of hoity-toity and it comes
in this dumb wrapper and i'm like i know
i can see through your bisque you're
full of [ __ ] you're a phony cookie yeah
whatever i like a short bread yeah yeah
the cookie sad you know what else taking
a [ __ ] flight back from springfield
missouri that's sad
so you know what embrace the sad have a
cookie treat yourself yeah nothing like
a connecting flight oh disgusting
the night after i taped my first half
hour special i flew to do some some like
gig in the middle of nowhere i was
wildly lonely just pulsing with
loneliness i was so aggressively single
and i go do this gig expressively single
that was like when i was remember when i
was like
hanging out at steakhouses because i
heard men hang out
really dark time for me i was just like
leering at strangers
i love a steakhouse that shows your
clientele i just i just went to saint
elmo's in indianapolis holy [ __ ] good
it's like the best thing it's like it's
where nick offerman always talks about
on oh
really his character yeah that's saying
elmo's indianapolis steakhouse [ __ ] what
about i'm sorry i mean i didn't mean to
mistake no there really wasn't much i
was going towards but i do feel like
there's something about
uh a men like grouped together uh
ignoring me
yes like just like guys at a work party
that has nothing to do with me i'm just
and i'm just sitting there layering it
like just
yeah it really feels if you're gonna be
ignored you want it to be at least uh
the caliber of a guy who's got like a
shrimp cocktail yeah
but i don't believe that i don't believe
that they're ignoring you i i'm sure
guys head on well i think it's alarming
when you're sitting at a bar and kind of
leering it's strange
it's like a bit of a red what are you
throwing a cocktail dress and sit at the
bar kind of there was a while where i
was like openly telling people this and
one of my friends was like
that's not okay
i think that's why
they got steakhouses like if you guys
want to hang i'll be in kids later and
then she's like too many
a cool people you're gonna pick up a
real old like a rich guy like a tycoon
it's funny that you say that because i
was hit on by a guy that was really
close to death and i was sitting at the
bar my friend was with me it's good to
bring like a winged person my friend is
like hello uh sumner some of the
redstone nice to meet you
would you like to control my oxygen tank
for the next few hours
like wait a minute rachel the sculptor
and he had the best line too it was like
the line i'd been waiting for my whole
life can't wait let's hear it dumb but
it was so funny there was like this big
painting up above the bar in keith's
steakhouse and it's like a big like
softic looking like kind of rolling
woman and he was like is that you are
you like it just made me laugh you know
he's like i'm sorry to say but it did
are you and then i turn around like
whoever this is like he's gonna be
inside of me this evening and he was
like osteoporosis old just like i love
your liver spots
no he was yeah like in his high 80s so
how was the sex
it was good he really punished me in
this way that i didn't realize i needed
to be punished right right he had his
nurse do it there was something about a
steakhouse that found like any place
that knows how to make a cocktail sounds
like a fun place it sounds like a
naughty place oh yeah it's oozing with
sexual vibes we were drunk and the
threesome i had with him in his home
attendant
i want to save him
hospice lady
[Laughter]
there needs to be more hospice porn yeah
yes
because all the porn ends the same way
this will end it a little differently
right you pull a plug nothing
pull out
nothing turns me on like a bedpan
i had speaking of porn i
i had a porn
on my phone one time and i was at a nail
salon on the upper east side i was like
nannying and i got off when i go to the
nail salon
packed upper east side nail salon my the
porn somehow opens on my phone it starts
blasting like wildly aggressive i was
like i am thank you
and i was like oh god
my hands were in the dryer oh my god oh
my god hands in the drive
like right when i started there was like
kids on the planet
but i'm like you know what i've listened
to your [ __ ] crime maybe you have to
listen to my [ __ ] yeah good point you
had that so it opened up and played like
that yeah yeah you just opened the
window it goes right where it left off
and right a long time ago but it was
like oh this is embarrassing you gotta
up those windows you know when you're
done i know i'm gonna learn some stuff
from you i need to learn
yeah you need to talk to i need to talk
to somebody that's been lying for the
last 20 years
it might be hard for you with the uh the
wet fingers though whatever norm it's
done will keep you safe for a long time
we do a patreon mark and i will walk you
through it yes
so what's your goat because i know the
ladies don't love the porn like my gal
is a [ __ ] animal in the sack she's
filthy she does things i've never seen
before but you put a porn on and she's
like
ah it's horrible i'm like she doesn't
want to watch with you you mean just
doesn't like it at all she never watches
even hates it when she rubs one out she
doesn't use it she's not a fan hmm
damn do you like it is there a type yeah
what what what's your go-to uh
i mean i don't watch that much and when
i do i'm sure it's like the beginning of
the trail of filth that you guys have
gone through especially throughout the
year it gets worse yeah yeah like i i
just watched like whatever i'm watching
i cut the 14 minutes in same same a lot
of scrolling
it's like saving private ryan the first
25 minutes i don't want to see it right
i want to see the real [ __ ] yeah it's
like m night shyamalan
let's see the twist yes
it's a man [ __ ]
he's been terrible
just watching the crying game
sorry one of the first porns i ever saw
was called uh it was something called i
think it was the horn or blind sister
but
[Laughter]
it was hilarious it was like this like
this this woman pull it up has i don't
know if that's the actual name but
that's that's what happens in the porn
um
and uh oh okay basically blindfolded
sister doesn't realize that it's her
brother's guy
what fun this is all right no it's it's
basically
is there a script for that is there like
a porno guy being like i need a twist
yeah basically they have some sort of
just filthy unacceptable
exhausting sex him and the
the first girl and then she's like
listen i gotta head to work doesn't it
doesn't even rinse herself just like
puts her hair up in a bun to go teach at
the local elementary school
and then she's like listen if you happen
to catch my sister just so you know she
might need some help around the house
this is how much porn there is it's that
like you put in a movie plot the movie
comes up oh yeah you put in a porn
synopsis you're getting like 80 and
you're like it's not that one yeah we
got like 10 blind porns cooking when you
pull that up but i'd like to know what
happens with the seeing eye dog what's
going on there
is that instead of helping
that's tuning in oh my goodness oh my
stars
[Laughter]
i mean [ __ ] that's like
what is that there
the horn of blind that's just larry
david oh it looks like a larry david
andy warhol kind of larry david yeah nah
i'd put that on my wall i feel like this
is a dangerous google
yeah you got that right
all right there's that seeing eye dog
episode that must be what it is
oh that's right that's right yeah you
sent me uh years ago you were talking
about how you like couples at ball bust
and you told me about uh what's his name
oh god geez why am i blanking on this
guy's name
the guy cool hand luke oh paul newman
paul newman i love pauline and uh the
wife uh joanne joanne woodward yeah
they're amazing they're so fun together
if you look up the old interviews of
them they're so hilarious with each
other and yeah the way he laughs at her
like this
him a lot and you could tell he just
loved it and there was this famous uh
quote about paul newman um yes they said
he said somebody asked him about like
why him and joanne woodward's marriage
lasted so many years because he was
married to her for i don't know what it
was like 20 30 like their whole
most of their lives
and uh he said why go out for um
hamburgers when you have steak at home
and it was like this famous quote and
they asked her about it she's like it
was just disgusting it was awful that
she was like i told him to stop
comparing me to meats
but they were like oh there's an
infamous impressive she's like yeah it's
not okay wow and he was laughing so hard
because this quote that everybody had
been like if only my husband would say
that about me right right rachel adapted
that yeah why stay home for burgers when
you go to a steakhouse
it's just cool that he's the hottest guy
in the world he's the coolest guy and
she's like ever singing all day
long loves it and you could tell
that he loved it and yeah yeah because
no one did it probably because nobody
did it yeah and uh they both told the
story of how they met and he was like i
came in i had this like seersucker suit
and i was meeting up with my agent and
she walked in and she was like oh his
suit was so ridiculous and he's laughing
so hard like he just she's like he came
in this absurd outfit just
and you could tell he just loves it he
loves that she just gives him like wild
amounts of [ __ ] yeah that's underrated
flirting is a little bit of
yeah just the right amount yeah people
overdo it with comics but it does yeah
but there's like a level of i will say
that's the fun thing about like i have
many a complaint about my husband but
being married to a firefighter cause
like i give him so much and he truly
loves it he's really cool about that
he likes that he doesn't firemen don't
give a [ __ ] about that kind of stuff
like no like we'll have sex and
afterwards i'll be like you really stuck
it up that time like
that was unacceptable laughs so hard to
be like i did right like it gave way to
and he just likes it like he doesn't
care at all yeah he is he is awesome
about i've seen i've seen you [ __ ] on
him and he takes it and it's like
it's playful i mean there's a skill to
ball busting the right way and that's
why like
you appreciate it you're like oh they
put thought into this yeah and
firefighters are a lot like comedians in
the way that like you know you walk up
to the comedy table the seller like a
normal person a civilian as we would
call them walks up and we're just like
rolling their eyes like awesome guy
brought his girlfriend over for him we
have to speak with her or something yeah
some female comic brought her boyfriend
over and we have to engage my issue is
when they they don't want to hang out
with her so they bring her over and then
they go to the bathroom
now i'm babysitting the date they don't
want to be on right oh my god so where
are you from
okay yeah i can see why he left
i just realized how many times that's
happened to me oh my god
they do do that i'm literally catching
up with friends i haven't seen with
weeks and the and some comic will drag
over a date that they don't want to oh
yeah
and you're like so have you seen the
blind [ __ ]
you don't know what to say yeah the part
with the dog is fascinating but the rest
wasn't for me right
did that when i was roommates with
charade because he would he would invite
girls over and
right you live in a rock um we live in a
railroad apartment and i feel like i
think this is a new york thing i feel
like if you're not from new york you
don't know it's a shotgun yeah it's like
so it's like you to go to
who lived in the back and who lived in
the front oh it was in the back then the
kitchen was in between and then the
bathroom was through my room so you had
to walk through my room to get to the
back so to use the bathroom it's like an
old law tenement you know we lived in
active squalor we've been doing stand up
for like you know a year wow and he
would get just like wild amounts of ass
and he would bring these women over and
and he would try to use me as part of
the oiling process to get them to trust
him i would try to look at them like
through eye contact and be like you're
making a terrorist
this is a violently bad idea but he
would like make me have basically had
this quick small talk with them so that
he could be like look female roommate
why not have me inside of you let me
know
you're making a terrible mistake the
ultimate wing woman though yeah i feel
like remember when we tried to do that
because me and sam were both single and
i was like and you can wing me and i'll
wing you and sam went out with me and it
was just really alarming when i came
with you it works like a charm but then
when you came with me and i'm like and
you talk to guys and then i'll talk to
them because i'm like too shy to
actively speak some guy talk to rachel
i'm just hammered like you like her
it was a disaster you'd be like yeah so
the knicks and they were just like what
are you guys trying to do to me and the
guys
they like yeah it was they weren't okay
we used to go to that bar swift all the
time in order it's funny we'd like go
out like meet people then we would just
like
sit at the bar and eat artichoke pizza
and get drunk yeah just always backfire
it shows how hard it was like before
apps and internet like you had to really
be vulnerable and put yourself out there
get drunk and sit at a bar oh my god
back in the day you would like walk up
like hey yeah i guess people still do
that but it's it's different it's
different yeah especially with younger
people i imagine it's a it's a new world
oh they won't know young people won't
know what it's like to have to approach
someone it's i guess maybe when they're
in like sixth grade you probably have to
learn it but like
when you're when you're an adult you
don't or a teenager even like i mean i
guess there's no tinder for like 13 year
olds but there might be yeah yeah i will
say those are the two moments that i
don't like envy being a man at all
really moments where i see it when men
have to hit on somebody i'm like oh my
god that's that's enough for me to want
out you know and the moment where like a
man meets another man for the first time
that he doesn't know at all there's this
weird oh yeah like i want no part of
that they'll be like i'll just go up
buddy they give like a free hit in the
back thing's good everything's okay like
i'm like not all of that would happen
i'll happily take all kinds of wild
unacceptable nonsense just not have to
meet be a man meeting another man for
the first time that is weird and but the
lady meeting is gonna be weird too like
the two pretty girls meeting there's
some real like
i like it thanks yeah you're right i
love your dress yeah and you're like oh
boy yeah i hate each other that's true
that is a loaded moment as well but
there's something about when guys meet
that it's frightening yeah it's like
planet earth like danger i feel like
some of them want to be like how much
you bench and you're like oh [ __ ] yes
exactly it's always like sizing each
other up yeah yes what are you six one
six two yeah
that is a that's a thing
that's why it's nice to be tall because
you guys are just like oh yeah i'm
taller than you
yeah yeah six one how much you pull in
financially every year yeah
yeah where do you live it's just like
what you're like all right jesus i know
that that happens a lot you're right the
man and men are [ __ ] me there is an
energy it's especially the bar once out
it's mostly younger men it's mostly yeah
really i think so or long island what do
you mean i think it's like when you're
young there's that insecurity and but
also yeah long island energy like the
long island meathead terrifying i mean i
have a bit about about like when
firefighters meet each other like this
oh yeah there's something about that new
york like type of like well there's a
god everything's okay it's good
beautiful tell you what dinner date it's
about family
yeah
it's about family i always say how they
always feel like they're about to admit
something they can't hold anymore
beautiful little crate goes by fast all
right goes by real fast first wife diane
you know like there's always a [ __ ]
drink i ran over a kid
sorry yeah no they can drink i mean
those are those are like dudes oh yes at
my wedding there was just like oh that
was that was hilarious i mean wildly
drunk firefighters i thought i was like
comics drink if i said the firemen i'm
like oh firemen because a lot of comics
are sober yeah
yes
and a lot of firemen need to be
yeah no it's a whole nother thing
because they're i mean they're like i
wonder if they've been drunk in the bell
rings like is that everything no they
can't be drunk at work anymore but they
like to tell fun stories yeah they do
they tell fun stories about like back in
the 70s
absolutely
i caught a fire truck 40 minutes ago
yeah we wrapped it around the pole
yeah we're at wendy's support the
drive-through
do you want anything
we'll bring it to you
pete's firefighter buddies called me
like
hammered once i mean while pete is his
captain right so he's his boss
and it's so cool to say i'm a captain i
know i know so man i put his hat on
right after sex all the time really like
a salute please respect the ranks that's
pretty inspect
with a fireman hat on that's pretty
great
but i actually put his whole uniform on
once but he's so anal like neat that i
was like oh i'll put a uniform on and do
like some sort of [ __ ] jig the fact
that i caught it horizon i'm aware is
not arousing but i came in he's like not
the other one do the other one because
that's the one i need to wear tomorrow
it's not gonna work anymore don't make
me break out the iron just to [ __ ] you
here come on right right
but he when he was promoted to captain
they did like a special ceremony there's
like a captain ceremony you guys
there's so much [ __ ] material in
these places so we go to this big
auditorium and each firehouse that knows
that guy's about to be promoted they
have a big sign like peter brennan you
know like 118 ladder 118 and then pete
was like listen when you arrive at the
stadium or whatever where he's being
promoted there's a guy with a bullhorn
it's like guys upstairs you know who
yous are shut up all right show some
respect okay i mean it's
incredible scene and so when i get there
he's like listen when you arrive at the
place because pete was sitting down like
at the front he's like a couple of my
guys are gonna like you know walk you up
i gave him your number you know and they
all all their names are like he has him
in his phone it's like jew steve or
something yeah you're getting juiced
dude white dan did you steve in the
lobby and they'll walk you up or
whatever
and then he was like and like you know
drunk
ted or something i'm trying to change
the name
[Laughter]
that's a long name
[Laughter]
so i meet the guy in the lobby and i'm
like already it's like a very it is like
the beginning of a porn like my friend
will take care of you or maybe just
supported my own mind but so he's like
the guys will watch you like they'll
take care of you during the ceremony
then i'll meet you after so then i meet
these guys and we chat we're hanging out
they were really fun you know animals
like myself we had a great time then
afterwards we go to this bar we have a
few drinks and then we go home and then
it like
we hadn't like been living together or
had i don't think we had sex yet so i go
back to my apartment and then at four in
the morning there was like seven missed
calls from the guy that was supposed to
meet me in the lobby of the promotion
ceremony oh
or the guy that i did meet there and i
listened to the messages and he's like
listen
that's incredible
the first one is like i'm just here to
pick you up
uh message seven you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] lied to me
if your house ever catches on fire we're
not coming they did get more and more
problematic
the first one was like listen i respect
pete i respect that he's gonna be a camp
and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever and
he's like but i'm going [ __ ] rescue
i'm going blue that's what they call
like the special ops firefighters they
say going rescue those are the guys that
have like cranes and going to like the
river and [ __ ] it's pretty amazing he's
like he's gonna be a cap whatever i'm
gonna be [ __ ] blue i would love to
have little blue babies with you
wow and he's like so it's so [ __ ]
brave man it really is like it's insane
it is insane it's great they get a pass
for drinking that much because of how
brave it is no that's why they drink
because all this [ __ ] they see like they
see some serious stuff right
and they go into fires and they love
going to fires and
if he doesn't go to a fire he gets upset
that he missed it i mean really they
hate missing fires and they complain
about the guys that got their job
whoa
they'll be like [ __ ] 240 they catch
all the good [ __ ] fights
[ __ ] beautiful fire in a high rise
should have been us
it must be a rush i mean as dangerous as
it is it's very similar besides the hero
part because we're narcissists but
there's a lot of weird similarities with
comics like they're adrenaline junkies
and they love their jobs that's i think
that's the reason that like he's i've
seen their bodies it's not that similar
they've got biceps and they can lift
weights yeah that's true we're complete
yeah we're but they have a lot just like
us they have a lot of down time they're
eating chili they're playing foosball i
love that the chili part looks funny i
love it the down time of any job looks
fun like i look at the mob i'm like well
you're just in like a [ __ ] cookout
that looks great and then they gotta
murder people and you know intimidating
sure you know the the part of the fire
department it just looked fun it just i
know you're just making me i love making
chili that's my favorite thing to make
they all cook firefighters all cook and
that's when you walk into the firehouse
you feel that same feeling as somebody
must walk feel when they walk up to the
comedy cellar table it's just like
the chemicals change in the room like
you've changed the chemicals because
you're coming but i do feel like they
like comedians fire yeah for sure then
once they know i'm a comic i like they
don't see me as quite as the same as the
like they get a kick out of stand-ups
but they came to a lot of our shows when
we were doing those they always come out
to my shows now
one week you weren't there there was
some firemen there and they were so cool
and they were uh we were chatting
afterwards they were just cracking me up
one of them was just like yeah i got
[ __ ] covered he goes he goes i was
[ __ ] sick he [ __ ] for two weeks it
was [ __ ] horrible
and he was just cracking he was just
making me laugh just as just there's
something about some of their energies
that's like so when you see [ __ ] like
that you give no [ __ ] yes and that's
something it's refreshing i think that's
why i like firemen yeah you don't give a
[ __ ] and they're for very different
reasons that we don't give you right
active heroes but they don't they don't
give a [ __ ] like they don't care about
it we don't give a [ __ ] because we're
tired and we're phoning it and half the
time they don't give a [ __ ] because they
could they know they could die
absolutely and they secretly it's like
nurses you ever have nurses in the
audience they're always great crowds
because they've seen people [ __ ]
themselves and blood splatters and all
that [ __ ] and it's like a full release
for them yeah they need to laugh some
people want to laugh some people need
draft like they need to laugh so totally
i did a gig
me and like five open mikers did a gig
in deep pennsylvania early on in comedy
and we all bombed they were super nice
but we just sucked at comedy the only
laugh
that i got was we were did the show in
front of all their
like their uniforms and everything we're
hanging up with their names you know
like gonzalez johnson whatever with the
helmet and everything and i was like oh
i'm bombing i go oh johnson we all know
he's gay and they went
ah
that's the only laugh i got they're all
shaking johnson like he is gay oh man
and then i bombed you know for another
20 minutes but yeah it is amazing people
who have been through [ __ ] like i
remember i did it was me and scott
chaplin years ago i love scott we did a
funny guy
oh he's the best he's so funny and we
did a gig in warwick
uh
delaware or whatever it is of rhode
island whatever the [ __ ] it was it was
it was
it was one of those places that probably
rhode island and it was in a movie
theater it was horrible it was like a
comedy zone back then
in a movie theater so scott's like uh is
it okay if i don't watch
what's your set uh grownups 2 is playing
next door i'm like all right go ahead
knock yourself out
uh so you know we go up and it's like
all the crowds kind of sucked there and
then we did one show and they're like
it's bought out by a breast cancer
benefit and i have to tell you it was
all women who had breast cancer and they
were the best crowd i've ever had wow
they just believe [ __ ] everything
they were so cool yeah
and there's something about that [ __ ]
when like rachel's right when you need
it it is well the people who get upset
about comedy are tend to be the most
privileged kind of highfalutin people
who can who can sit there and analyze it
and go never bothered me yeah yeah
exactly
the way you're protected
because it's a privilege to be offended
there's like it's like there's a lot
less room for those kinds of emotions in
some people's lives right like i was
asking my brother because he's a
therapist at like an inner city school
in in dc and like and they have it just
dealt with insane amounts of adversity
and poverty and a lot of the kids are
just like immigrants who've dealt with
insane levels of unacceptable violence
and
and i'm like what do you what do you
deal with like how do you deal with all
the kids getting triggered by language
and like this new culture he's like this
doesn't happen
we triggered for guns exactly i don't
hear that word i hear that word very
rarely like you're dealing with like
active violence and real emergencies and
the immediacy of poverty and other
things like that yeah totally completely
agree i can't believe i'm drunk but i
made that point somehow oh that was good
you [ __ ] stuck the landing on that is
that one good i want to try it oh dude i
tried it taste that yeah i love a
cucumber in a drink it's such a fine
idea
dude you're killing this what is that
called that's the cucumber rush
holy [ __ ] and what a voice too huh i
know this guy's like
dude this is so good i shouldn't just
because i'm on the thing but i i you
know
a small one all right give me a hand
give me a taste all right
good cocktail really seems to kid but
the funny thing is when that guy left me
that long series of voicemail messages
was like you and me little blue babies
then he calls back he's like [ __ ] pete
i bet he's got a baby penis
he's like we have two babies together
it's so funny that they'll literally go
into fires together but then they're
like yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] your wife
i'll give a [ __ ]
fascinating i play the whole thing for
peter like well your buddy
because he's so not jealous i was like
he'll barely care about this i played
the entire thing he's just dying
laughing yeah later on
couldn't give a [ __ ] later on i'm like
did you ever even like mention that to
him like if somebody did that to my
boyfriend i might like
at least give him a [ __ ] about it yeah
like nah i never did you know like
[Laughter]
i totally get that
but i do feel like i always ask him i'm
always like
like if i how long would i have to go
missing before you would look for me
because i feel like it would be like no
i don't think he would look for me
immediately he's always emptying the
dishwasher
i'm like you would empty the dishwasher
before you would look for me right
he's like i might i might
but but also i do feel like that is part
partly
related to the first responder thing
like it's like
he knows his friend's drunk whatever
like when you deal with active emergency
to that extent he's just like yeah you
know what i mean like and i love to give
him [ __ ] about that but the other side
of it is like
he's just not jealous he's the only guy
that's like fully accepted my
you don't have room for that [ __ ] when
you're yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's
why we don't get offended about stuff
either because we're like
oh what oh i didn't think i mattered
like it's weird when somebody's like
that bothered me i'm like well stuff
bothers me all the time but i just move
on oh we're into like the when it comes
to comedy we're like into the bdsm
you know we're into the dark end yeah
that's our humor because we we went
through open mics and
we find we find dark [ __ ] funny so that
when they like find like can you come
believe a comedian made this joker laugh
at this and it's like [ __ ] yeah right
that's we're the people that would make
that [ __ ] up joke of course of course
like billy you got my gender wrong and
i'm like oh oh sorry but if you got my
job if you got my dinner i'd be like oh
yeah i'm a guy like i wouldn't think
twice about it you know if i was on the
phone or like is this a woman i'd be
like yeah whatever you know that
wouldn't bother me but it's a thing now
yeah everything's everything's good
everything's fine man [ __ ]
i mean no it's like i really feel that
way we talked about it last week but
like you hear about how [ __ ] divided
we are and then you just go outside yes
it looks all right to me sun is shining
i will say this people are always like
like every time i i got into an uber the
other day and like and the driver was
like what do you think about this people
getting offended by everything huh what
do you think about that is like he asked
me what i did for a living and i just
made the mistake of telling him i was a
comic and he's like he's like that's it
yeah that's ridiculous huh and i'm like
yeah no it is and then he's like
and then they put you know what they put
in this vaccine i'm like how did i cost
that's the problem i'll tell you what
they got in there he's like i'll tell
you what they got a chip to control your
brain i'm like wow that is the [ __ ]
that's the door to that next statement
like he was just sure that i was gonna
what if something just activated my
brain i was like kill uber driver
kill uber right
but i do feel like if you actually go
out to crowds and when you're on the
road
it hasn't changed that much no life is
pretty good and you and you talk to
people and you're like most people are
[ __ ] cool yeah i think there's like a
blogger that's gonna get misunderstand
something i've said sure but i feel like
when you actually go out there's just
people that they're working too hard for
this [ __ ] though i know what you guys
were saying about privilege i do think
that people who are working super hard
when you go on the road they don't have
time to give a [ __ ] they kind of roll
their eyes at it and
yeah it's everything's fine people have
kids they have jobs they commute
yeah you know yeah exactly kids like you
have three kids you think you're [ __ ]
tweeting about a comedy special being
offensive yeah you're wiping [ __ ]
exactly oh your mom is sick there's
always something going on you know you
got a mortgage yeah i feel like most
people that have like multiple kids are
like they're already active alcoholics i
feel like a lot of my friends that have
a lot of kids that's how you have that
many kids you just started drinking
heavily parents were i would think of
tom papa's bit how he used to drink it
like bars now he drinks over the sink
over the sink that's hysterical so funny
he's funny what does he say that's so
he's one of my favorite jokes he's like
uh man tom poppy got three kids you got
a wife at home man oh man
what's what's the hardest part about
doing the road he's like well the
hardest part is uh not whistling while i
pack
i mean that is
pitch perfect comedy yeah he's a he's a
great comic i'm shiny again oh no you're
not we're all doing great you're drunk
that's the
how do you hang with pete i mean you
just sit and watch him
down twelve bud like he doesn't drink a
lot of fireworks don't drink yeah
because he can't like once they it's
just like a lot they see on the job so
but he i've only seen him drinking no he
would he stopped drinking a while ago
and he'd be more likely to uh
to
smoke pot or something oh that's the
move now yeah everybody's going to pot
i'm not a big punk guy i'm not either me
neither it accentuates every quality
i've been trying to erase it it's very
similar to this yeah exactly what it
does to me i think that's part of the
reason we're all kind of close is
because we've all we all are like hang
at the bar drink people and we have been
since i've known both of you right
yeah booze settles the mean [ __ ] weed
brings it up for me me too i like start
to get think people don't like me and
they want me to leave and i alcohol i
don't care if they don't like me i'm
like [ __ ] you exactly it softens the
piece of [ __ ] yeah i feel like
especially like i feel like neurotic
jews and i feel like you are one at
heart like with us like you you really
are i'll take it yeah yes i mean i i
feel like we that's the yeah those are
the qualities we've been trying to iron
out yeah that's what drinking does for
us we bring more of them up i don't need
that no there's a real supply and demand
issue with those emotions that weed
brings out in me but it must be a
personality thing because some people
just like i smoke weed i feel great i
smoke when i wake up it helps my day i'm
like oh my god if you made me smoke weed
in the morning i would just oh people
were like it's like therapy to me i'm
like oh does it bring up your mother
like what the [ __ ] like what is
for you
for me therapy is therapy it's not
[ __ ] no like this like i would never
say alcohol with therapy yeah good point
i mean it's a quick fix you know if
you're going through it's a great short
term solution that's the word i
overthink everything and so weeds got me
overly dissecting i'm like i need less
dissecting in my life yeah i need to
slice up my
miniature moments much less but when i
smoke weed i'm just like
in the corner just kind of quaking
wondering my like roommate wants me to
move out or not
and your roommate's your husband
yeah i know it's i i know you guys mean
i i start to think all the bad yeah the
bad takes over and then there's always
that one guy goes you got to get the
right strain i'll tell you the strain
again you're like ah i've tried them all
they all suck this one i don't believe
in the strain stuff though they all make
me actively paranoid so this one relaxes
you i'm like well
i'm not okay yeah you gotta try this new
weed strain maybe it's you that's a
really good one
yeah my mind is not that it really makes
me realize i don't have like a stealthy
mind like my mind is very like it's very
fragile as soon as i just have a little
bit of weed just a whisper and i'm i'm
not okay because i don't have a waspy
mom i have a jew mom so my mom is never
like hiding [ __ ] my mom is always like
my mom will never just like let [ __ ] go
she'll just say sam we're not mad we're
just disappointed
like what does she get disappointed oh
ev when i was a kid i was just always
drunk and she was just always like very
disappointed in you i threw up at my
sister's graduation
seventh grade
i vomited everywhere and and i vomited
so hard that the blood vessels
the blood vessels popped in my face whoa
you got the red eye
not just that just
spots wow
it's so hard holy moly well that's scary
for a mom to see yeah just yeah it's
like i'm disappointed you can't hold
your boobs
like you're like such a funny word for
that she's like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
damn do you have any wrecks rachel oh
yeah what are you watching what are you
loving what are you liking i love
murder yes i like to watch i don't know
what that says about me but every lady
doesn't sleep until i've seen like the
wives with knives
have you heard norman's bit about true
crime no oh yeah it's an old bit about
how i got caught watching uh gay porn
for a second and she called me out i was
like well you watch murder and she's
like well you're just doing that to uh
she's like i just watched that so i know
what to do if i ever get in that
situation i'm like well that's why i'm
watching gay porn
that's hilarious why were you watching
gay porn i made it up i wasn't
i needed a parallel for the people this
is a fascinating premise to make up like
that's like that well i i have watched
gabriel such a window into
norman's mind oh you have i have yeah
just to like let me try it let me be 100
sure i mean i've blown a guy
i'm
joking but uh
yeah i watched it just like let me see
and it was way too aggressive way too
much
dick and you know wasn't for me that's a
great critique of gay porn there's too
much dick yes too much dick
it's like going to a thai restaurant
being like what's with all the noodles
i hate noodles
i like my noodle
that's it
i like my restaurant what so what murder
are you watching um i loved well i loved
mine hunter i love happy valentine's day
it's an incredible show
amazing and i read the book it's one of
the best books i've ever had in my life
i started it i got it
they didn't i'm so upset i think it has
something to do with contracts or
something because they were supposed to
come back
it's one of the best books i've ever
read in my life mine i started it
because
i got to go incredible [ __ ] i watch
it because of you too so good and i was
actually the guy's a badass he was like
solving crimes in the sleep i mean i
find it oh fascinating he never slept
when he slept he'd be like let me try to
solve it in my sleep yes because he had
so many cases he was one of the guys
that like coined the term serial killer
and he had solved so many um
serial killing hummus like serial killer
type homicides and um that's not that
was a mess of a sentence but like i said
a pretty little lip but he um he was
brilliant and one of the chapters of the
book he explains how he could look at
just crime scene photos and and write up
what's called a character profile and he
would be able to profile the perpetrator
just by seeing the photos they don't
tell me anything else about the case i
just need to see the photos i don't want
anything else in my mind i just want to
see the crime scene photos and then he
would see the photos and one of the
cases he got he said the killer has a
lisp and he [ __ ] did how do you know
that wow explains that he's like look
sometimes i'm wrong but there's
different styles of killer and there's
one style of killer that comes that is
basically amazing that mark just farted
i hear murder i have my fart
there's one that
that is like somebody that's
self-conscious about something and
that's why they kill so they approach
the woman in a way that's either they're
really openly angry or they're self-con
there's something they're hiding and in
this case he went through all the
potential things a man could be hiding
her self-conscious about and then
decided that he thought he was like it
was a guess that it was a lit and it was
a [ __ ] lisp wow but he and he would
guess what color a car was a man would
drive because he said man would choose a
certain color car for different reasons
like i find that [ __ ] so that's amazing
that's incredible fascinating and a lot
of the guys that would be chosen to be
in the fbi or the like cia at this time
they would be kind of c students and the
fbi would ask you to go it because they
would be good at something else probably
i relate to this because i was like a d
student but
they were like there was some kind of
inattentiveness to certain things but an
attentiveness to other things that would
make them kind of fbi tap them which is
what they called it real time and they
would just kind of tap him to be an fbi
agent and they kind of watched the
trajectory of him i just think that's so
fascinating amazing wow first of all the
people are watching you at all nobody's
watched me for any period of my life
i was like you say you're a bad student
but you're you're such a smart person i
mean you always like i was a while i
know but you always emergency
you always have like the best take like
also not just like do you read a lot but
you feel like you're always uh
you always have like a great article to
read you always uh
you always
have great uh insight no you do
comfortable oh she doesn't like the
comments i know but it's like comics do
this they they
a lot of them we know i mean probably
ourselves included we we knock ourselves
down a little bit but like yeah you know
but anyway so i can tell it's making you
uncomfortable you stink you're the worst
is that better i need it to try to
internalize this no no you're uh
it's interesting you've shared a lot of
this murder stuff with me and it's like
it is it is fascinating that you can
just crack this [ __ ] like
a lot of these a lot of these rapists
have really tiny dicks i think right
these a lot of these uh like east area
rapists that guy oh my god that's a
crazy story right yeah he would like
snack after he would assault oh yeah
that's the kind of [ __ ] that i'm
fascinated terrible ad for ruffles
potato chips
can't just have one
like hang out and make andy's mac and
cheese afterwards
i can't know why he does that to me that
makes me more nervous like don't look at
my
fridge [ __ ] me in the ass but my
cupboard is embarrassing
but i just find those types of insights
so fascinating to be able to read people
is the coolest skill so cool whole world
and he it is a fascinating that's what
we try to do with comedy you're right
that's probably why i admired it so much
but i was a wild [ __ ] in school like uh
they were doing they did a lot of scans
on me i was always being scanned scan
skin like literally brain scans like
suction
because i was that
dumb
that people were like
why is she like this we need an
immediate solution or suggestion to how
we can help her because they thought i
had various different learning
disabilities including something called
figure ground where you can't tell the
difference between one person speaking
and a sea of voices but it was just that
i was bored i guess by whatever the
teacher was saying right um and then so
we would my parents were always scanning
me and i remember one time my mom and
dad arguing about me and i hurt them in
the middle of the night and my dad goes
she's not normal carrot [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh that'll keep you up at night huh and
then my mom was like well we'll scan her
again
but i really believe that my emergency
levels of stupidity were just
infuriating and harming my entire family
that's i had similar stuff i remember my
mom fighting with my teacher in third
grade and he was like he's special needs
and she was like he's not he's not and
then she's like let's get out of here
and she grabbed me and ran out wait wait
so you really struggled in school too oh
my god i did this thing where uh we were
circling instruments you know to be a
page full of objects like you know a
hammer a nail a violin a piano a book
bag or whatever and it said circle all
the instruments like musical instruments
so i circled them all and then i circled
a saw and so they're like we see he's
he's stupid he circled a saw and my mom
was like well don't just call him stupid
let's ask him why he circled the saw and
then we'll ask him why are you stupid
yeah
why are you an idiot so i she goes why'd
you circle the song i said i saw marx
brothers movies where chico plays a saw
and she was like oh there you go
stop yelling at my kid and calling him a
[ __ ] he saw a movie that's really cool
that your mom asked that follow-up
question yeah it's cool that you were in
the comedy at that age and yeah the
comedy and it was the marx brothers
which is like pretty high level comedy
well my mom was so out to lunch i was
like i love comedy i love bill murray i
love chris farley and she's like i got
you out to lunch streaming on youtube
right now like she got it for you yeah
she went and bought mark's brother's vhs
tapes and i was like
but i still watched him but i love him
yeah you wanted i wanted eddie murphy or
whatever but i remember eddie murphy was
the best yeah
he's just one of those guys you knew
immediately was like a wild star oh
nothing he was going to be
but a star he has
if anyone has it it's a young eddie
murphy but yeah so i circled the saw and
it was nice that she
dug in a little like why the saw instead
of just going that's so cool that's so
important yes that's so wonderful as a
parent that she did that for you and
that you remember it of course those
little moments especially after so much
rejection like when i even smell a
school like when i was nanning and i
have to go pick a kid up at a school
yeah it would just take me back to all
that wild rejection and terrible
feelings i had at school of just being
such a failure
and
and i still remember though this one
teacher that said i was like in the
bathroom and i was like washing my hands
and she was like you're you know you're
smart and i was like paralyzed with fear
at a compliment just like i was just
like really and she's like yes you say
and write smart things and then she
walked out of the bathroom and i'm like
that carried me through like 10 more
years of my life and probably helped me
be a comedian just that one person
then just didn't see me as some kind of
emergency level problem right same same
yeah i think that's so important i know
we should we should wrap this we gotta
do a paper oh
and we're going long but you're right
you got rachel plug you have a new album
out with jessica yes jessica carson is
who's the funniest person i love kirsten
she's so hysterical i just was with her
in l.a promoting our prank album and it
really ranked we made a prank album and
that's how what got us through covet i
was like pregnant covered married to a
firefighter she lost her dad like her
dad passed or in covid and we just
decided to go
make these prank calls and just like do
what we did when we were in high school
that made us laugh it just took me back
to that place of just before there was
the business and all these other sure
just laughing with a friend and being
silly and absurd
and uh and we made a prank album and
it's called the call girls and it's now
for sale everywhere you can buy that
kind of thing like spotify and itunes
and apple music and everywhere else yeah
jessica kirsten follow her too she's so
funny one of the funniest our hardest
follows in new york oh my god she slays
kills what about um she gets like she
got like two standing ovations in the
same night when i was with her and wow
wow just did rogan too she's i feel like
she's yeah she's very much blowing up
right now she's awesome man i love her
that's a great photo that's great
what how about club dates coming up any
any place people can see you on the road
yes i'm in um i'm in uh
i can barely think right now um
st louis
and if you go to my website
rachel.feinstein.com i haven't put up
that site but i'm in a new i mean i
haven't put up that specific gig but i
think my next gig is a is a comedy
festival in st louis i'm at the dc
improv soon i'll add all that stuff too
right i haven't added either of those
dates to my website but those are some
other ones as well i like women
spokane oh great club nice set what is
this dos
yes and um i'll be at the dc in province
some other places and i mean if you're
upstate i'll be at this poured candle
bar upstate i think in like a couple
weeks i'll post it all on instagram just
follow me on instagram there you go
rachel feinstein underscore thanks guys
for having me and i'm real drunk we love
you what do you got man i'm all over the
road as well uh next week i'm i think
i'm in portland oregon
um in atlanta i'm in dr grins and ran
grand rapids um boy i'm all over the
place let's see what else are we cooking
with
uh
laugh boston love boston break
california vancouver and new orleans
royal oak and uh yeah milwaukee so yeah
check mark normancomedy.com
watch our specials out to lunch get on
the patreon where you gonna be at fatty
denver
phoenix san francisco dallas miami uh
all over samurail.com
shows yeah i can't we can't wait for all
these gigs so looking forward to it see
you guys soon listen to the patreon
patreon.com we might be drunk pod leave
us a nice review
uh gotham studios always the best beers
we love you yeah uh and uh keep
listening we love you yes here here and
follow rachel on everything social media
rachel feinstein yeah not the sculptor
no [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
bye